wir wollen jetzt mit jemandem sprechen
der von diesen harten maßnahmen wie
andere unternehmer hart getroffen wurde
gerhard bosselmann und zugeschaltet aus
seiner bäckerei in hannover und bevor
wir herr bosselmann darüber sprechen wie
sie die lage sehen würde ich gerne noch
einmal ein video zeigen dass im märz
entstanden ist und dass tatsächlich
viele menschen sehr gerührt hat der
mittelstand wird fallen gelassen
es ist eine katastrophe wir müssen uns
selbst helfen und sie als unsere kunden
können uns helfen und in schlechten
zeiten zu uns halten wie wir das auch
tun
ich möchte mich bei meiner belegschaft
bedanken die wundervolle bitte gehen sie
zu ihrem bäcker ob ergraute wrabetz
geheißen es ist völlig egal
gehen sie zu ihrem bäcker um die ecke
die bäcker aus hannover sind für sie da
ist scheißegal wie da ist gehen sie
einfach hin weil sie retten damit
arbeitsplätze der postmann sind 205 und
wir haben alle unsere jobs einen scheiß
angst herr bostelmann das war der
berührenden moment das video das sie
dort aufgenommen haben sagen sie uns wie
geht es ihnen heute und wie haben sie
den ersten block überstanden und machen
sie sich schon sorgen dass jetzt die
zweite kommt ach wissen sie zu einem
unternehmer gehört dass nach momenten
der emotionen die im unternehmen ja auch
nach einem alten familienbetrieb mal
erlaubt sein dürfen dann auch die
sachlichkeit wieder kommt der kampfesmut
wir sind aufgestanden und wir geben
wieder gas
auf der anderen seite sind wir sehr
zornig und verzweifelt verzweifelt über
die unvernunft die eine zweite welle
eventuell ermöglicht ich finde wir
sollten alle jetzt vernünftig sein und
auch das wort disziplin einmal wieder an
uns lassen
entscheidend ist aber dass wir die
probleme der ersten welle ja noch nicht
mal verdaut habe also es wird in die
schätzen wir einem vierteljahr zu einer
der größten insolvenz wellen im
mittelstand führen die deutschland je
gesehen hat mit einer
arbeitslosenzahl die sie sich im künsten
traum nicht vorstellen können das ist
jetzt keine angstmacherei das ist kein
szenario dass ich dahin male ich habe
mit ich habe ungefähr 1200 e mails
gekriegt aus dem ganzen mittelstand und
wir haben große große sorgen
sie sprechen von der
massenarbeitslosigkeit die auf
deutschland zukommen könnte aber nochmal
zurück gefragt wenn wir jetzt diese
zahlen sehen und auch die debatten in
deutschland sehen
über mögliche neue maßnahmen die da
kommen könnten beschreiben sie uns
einmal was würde das für sie ganz
persönlich bedeuten wenn er es zu einer
art zweitem locker und käme dass wir die
nicht nur für uns sondern für 80 prozent
des mittelstandes das sofortige aus sein
die kassen sind leer die
altersversorgungen sind aufgebraucht wir
haben ja gut gewirtschaftet in den
letzten jahren waren fleißig und sparsam
und hatten rücklagen diese rücklagen
sind völlig verzerrt